today during the coronavirus task force
briefing President Trump highlighted the
American men and women who are working
to keep this country running during this
pandemic here's what he said we're
taking aggressive action now as one
nation and one family so that America
can rebound stronger frankly stronger
than ever before and we recognize that
while many American workers can work
from home many others cannot many of our
health care providers first responders
and men and women into the food service
and manufacturing are showing that
they're showing up and standing up to
provide us with the goods and services
we need and joining us now is the vice
president of the United States also
heading up the president's Task Force on
Corona Vice President Mike Pence great
to have you back sir thank you for being
with us thank you Sean
okay let's start we've got a lot of
ground to cover a lot of things are now
happening fluid but there's 15 days of
guidelines for the American people and
the the reason for the importance of
this well Sean first thank you for for
your efforts to convey the president's
coronavirus guidelines for America the
president unveiled yesterday and what
we're what we're pleased to learn is
being embraced by states and communities
and millions of American families are
what we believe is important for every
American to do over the next two weeks
to to significantly impact the spread of
the corona virus in the weeks and months
ahead all of our experts tell us and
they advise the President as he endorsed
these guidelines to avoid social
gatherings of more than 10 people - if
you're sick stay home if there's someone
in your home contracts the corona virus
that everyone should stay home all of
those recommendations are part and
parcel of an effort by our experts
endorsed by the President to limit to
limit the reach of the corona virus over
the coming weeks and months and we and
and we need every American every
American
business to step forward and recognize
that if we act now if we act now we can
limit the spread of the coronavirus
significantly and ultimately save lives
let's go through a little checklist if
we can I know you don't have a lot of
time how quickly will the drive-up
testing sites and walmart and CVS
parking lots targets etc I wish I could
name them all because I think they're
they've really stepped up to the plate
how long do you expect those online for
those people that needs tests and how
big a part of the country will be
covered well what's happening is that as
of last week 10 states around the
country had initiated drive-through
testing centers but Sean they were using
the old manual testing methods in labs
which could only test about 40 to 60
people a week because President Trump
two weeks ago brought together the top
commercial labs in the country and
because the FDA moved in record time now
we have what are called high throughput
tests automated tests that can literally
test thousands of people a day for the
coronavirus and and I couldn't be more
proud
Admiral Jerrod and the dedicated people
at US Public Health Service and FEMA are
working with states around the country
to build on the state's efforts to
establish drive-through and in community
coronavirus testing centers those are
coming online starting tomorrow and
they'll be widening their scope around
the country we're going to be supporting
state efforts we're going to be working
with them to make sure that those great
retailers which are CVS and Target and
Walgreens and Walmart that have are
opening their parking lots for
drive-thru centers are included but the
American people can be confident that
now that we have the commercial labs
around the country with those high-speed
automated tests you're literally going
to see tens of thousands of tests in the
days and weeks ahead for the American
people let's talk about well we have
enough of medical equipment respirators
ventilators I know as I said some more
released by the Pentagon that's really
good news and a
worst-case scenario also I talked to dr.
Fuji he likes to say he wants to err on
the side of caution worst case scenario
is what you're planning for are we ready
for that for example cities that might
be overwhelmed would we have triage
capabilities doctors on standby with all
the equipment that they need the tents
the medical supplies supporting staff
that we could c-130 cargo plane them
over and they could set up and they're
on the ground to take on more capacity
if hospital systems are overwhelmed well
Sean today the president convened the
nation's top industrial suppliers names
that are familiar to you
Home Depot Amazon and others and and we
directed them today to to ensure that
those critical medical supplies are
being focused away from construction and
other industries and focused exclusively
on the needs of our healthcare industry
the president's made it clear this is
all hands on deck we're going to
continue to work with businesses we're
going to continue to work closely with
governor's I spoke to the governor of
New Jersey today I spoke to the governor
of Washington State yesterday we are
day-by-day evaluating what their needs
are because our priority is people that
that have contracted the corona virus
making sure they have the testing and
the care that every American would want
for their family and our second priority
right after it is our health care
workers Sean and president Trump has
made it clear that we're going to use
every effort of the federal government
every resource of the government as well
as harnessing the power of the private
sector to make sure our health care
workers have the personal protective
equipment that they need to do their job
safely mr. vice president I want to ask
you this especially on the economy we
know that there are checks going out
starting I believe in the next two weeks
people paying their taxes will get a
delay no penalties no interest there's
going to be small business loan
availability set up for those small
businesses
and relief for workers and relief for
those those industries in particular
Airlines the president has mentioned
cruise line industry directly impacted
through no fault of their own here we
may be spending close to a trillion
dollars Sean with presidents made clear
and every American be confident is we're
going to do whatever it takes
any hourly worker in this country who
feels like they may have contracted the
corona virus should stay home and they
shouldn't worry about missing a paycheck
we're working with Congress to ensure
that paid leave is available for
hardworking Americans but making sure
that this economy gets back on its feet
that Americans are able to weather this
time as is also a priority for President
Trump we're talking with leadership in
both parties on Capitol Hill and we're
very confident that as Congress did
before with the supplemental bill the
legislation that's moving through today
that will bring paid family leave and
cover the cost of a coronavirus test for
every American whether they have
insurance or not we're gonna build on
that an economic stimulus package that
will bring us through this time and and
when we are through the coronavirus as
the president said again today we know
this economy will come roaring back Sean
I mean all the fundamentals are there
and the best thing we can do for the
economy is what the president called on
every American to do yesterday in the in
the 15 days to slow the spread the more
we can do every single one of us to
prevent the spread in our family in our
community at our place of work the
sooner we will be through this it will
still be weeks and months to go but we
can lessen the impact of the corona
virus in the weeks and months ahead we
can save lives and as the president said
when when we defeat the corona virus in
the United States this economy will come
roaring back mr. vice president as
always thank you